الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد لاستعاده الارض
وهزيمه الروس حقيقه عسكريه ام خطه وهميه
وحرب نفسيه
[تصفيق]
الرئيس الاوكراني قال لويس ان الهجوم
المضاده جاهز وسيكون خلال اسابيع يلا في
رايي واعتبارا من اليوم نحن على استعداد
للقيام بذلك نود الحصول على معدات معينه
لكننا لا نستطيع الانتظار لشهود انا مؤمن
بقوه باننا سننجح لكن لا اعرف كم سنحتاج
من الوقت
مستشار زيلينسكي للشؤون الخارجيه استبعد
الخطه العسكريه وقال لصحيفه ان اوكرانيا
تفتقد لاسلحه تكفي لشن هجوم مضاد
الجيش الاوكراني نشر فيديو دعائيا اسمه
الخطط تحب الصمت يطلب فيه من المواطنين
عدم تصوير او افشاء اسرار التحركات
الميدانيه للجنود في العلوم العسكريه عاده
ما يبقى موعد الهجوم وخطته امرا سريا وهو
ما لا ينطبق على خطه اوكرانيا المعلنه في
شتى وسائل الاعلام الغربيه وعلى نقيض فان
وسائل الاعلام الروسيه تفند الهجوم
الاوكرانيه المزعوم يعتقدون في موسكو ان
الامر حرب نفسيه تسعى لزعزعه ثقه الجنود
الروس على الخطوط الاماميه وان هجوم
اوكرانيا المضاد لن يتعدى مسيرات وصواريخ
بعيده المدى تضرب العنق الروسي وهو ما
يحدث هذه الايام
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والو
ثائقيه تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على
اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات